- I have to ask you about this
because I feel like so
many people come on here
and have a Prince story and
I know Prince is on New Girl.
So what, do you have a
story, a Prince story?
- Yeah well I know,
Prince really liked New
Girl which was cool.
We found out that he watched it.
- Like a lot of people, liked it.
- Prince is a wild like
and so he wanted to do the show.
Obviously Liz Meriwether then said come on
and when he came and he was walking around
he was talking to Zoey
and he was kind of where
you are and I'm here
and then I saw him look at
me and then he said to Zoey,
I would like to meet Nick now.
- Oh, he called you Nick?
- And Zoe looked at me
and obviously, whatever Prince wants,
so she looked at him like yeah.
So she walked over and she's
like hey Nick, come over here.
I was like hey and I met Prince
and he was as nice as it gets
and he wanted to live in
the reality of the show
and he wanted Nick and
Jess to be together,
so he said he'll do the show
if he could help them get together
and he got to live a little fantasy.
- Wait, he changed the
narrative of the story?
I love that!
- He wanted them together
and we wanted Prince.
- [Kelly] This is so powerful.
- Prince is, I mean, the best.
- What kind of power is that?
Yes, but I need them to get together
or I will not show up.
- He goes I'm happy to do it
if I'm part of them being together.
- Oh my gosh!
- The best.
- Did he call you Nick the whole time?
- Honestly, I'm such a fan that I think,
he also could have called me anything
and I would have responded.
- [Kelly] John.
- He could have called me
Shut up and get me my
coffee and I'd be like,
you got it.
- Got it!
- Didn't matter.
- Absolutely!
- I love that he was like
wouldn't do it unless they would.
That's amazing.